To analyze this line, we need to know where it hits the y axis, and at what
angle. This angle is generally referred to as the slope. Which is essentially
the amount that y changes, when x changes by 1 unit. In other words, when x
moves 1 unit from here to here, y changes from here. Note that this is a
positive relationship, and we want to find, what's the change in y when x
increases by 1 unit. That's the slope, but remember in the case of regression,
this line represents how much y is expected to change, when x changes by 1
unit. Therefore, when we write the equation for this line, we denoted it by y
hat. There are many ways to symbolize the y-intercept and slope. You may have
learned the generic y equals mx plus b, which at least in the United States, is
usually how it's taught. That's where m represents slope, and b represents the
y-intercept. But really, we can symbolize them any way we want. The important
thing is that once we decide on how to denote them, you have to remember that
and continue to use that later. We can also write it like this, because
addition can go in any direction. 2 + 3 is the same as 3 + 2. The slope times x
plus the y-intercept is the same as the y-intercept plus the slope times x.
Sometimes one of these, the slope or they y-intercept, might be negative. So
it's just important to keep that in mind. As long as we keep those negatives
and positives signs correct, the order doesn't matter. The slope and
y-intercept are called regression coefficients. And sometimes when we use
software to calculate their regression line, they'll present it in this first
way. For this lesson, we're going to use b to symbolize the slope, and a to
symbolize the y-intercept. Given this, what will be our generic equation for
the regression line? Select all that apply.